if you want to learn about robot culture
Kyoto is as good of a place to start as
any
for hundreds of years it has been the
showcase city for Japan's most famous
traditions from geishas to spectacular
temples
over in the University District you can
also find some of Japan's best
technological minds have come to
Doshisha University to dive deep into
Japan's love affair with robots with the
professor and one of Japan's most active
robot hobbyists at the Museum then where
am i oh no I only hired an impartial
height at the you gain of that there you
go keep oxygen got a guillotine oh gosh
she's don't talk chewy not eat it yeah
Q's got good news Takashi horino Chi
embodies a Japanese concept known as a
taco it refers to a person who obsesses
over something be it Hello Kitty sushi
for robots for Takashi robotics is more
than a hobby it's his passion most of
his free time goes into assembling these
things by hand out of 3d printed body
parts and electronics do you work on
these almost every day yes about two
hours almost every day most romo itsumo
college is very to look and I get it
that's cool yeah each one takes months
to build including the software for the
choreographed moves
but it's not all for show these robots
must fight to earn their keep akira
would i hit other robots oh yeah that
guy yeah
one of Takashi's robots recently took
first place in a competition making him
king of the otaku
and when you're the king there are
people that want to study you one of
Japan's foremost researchers into the
relationship between man and BOTS is
Hiro Fumi kutsuna an anthropologist here
at doe sheesha University I was looking
for you know that the passionate people
who work on robots I joined a group and
started to create my own robots and
YouTube met at this address Hiro felt
compelled to ask that Seinfeld II in
question what's the deal with Japan and
all those robots it's related to Japan's
sort of national quest to establish its
own identity and after the World War two
so after the sort of a devastation of
the whole land Japan started to rebuild
the nation through promoting the
peaceful use of science and technology
in that process I think many anime
creators and manga creators started to
ponder the kind of ideal relationship
between the Japanese and technology for
society suka now some who who is a
creator of astro boy hero is not alone
in pointing to the significance of astro
boy the manga series started in the
1950s and has a mad scientist-type
building an Android to replace his dead
son the saga goes on to explore what
life would be like if humans and robots
coexist it's a future that we're all
sure to experience soon enough
you